[Music]
with enough courage you can do without a
reputation
every problem has two handles you can
grab it by the handle of fear or the
handle of hope
[Music]
i want peace i want to see if somewhere
there isn't something left in life of
charm and grace
[Music]
the old guard dies but it never
surrenders
[Music]
most of the miseries of the world were
caused by wars and when the wars were
over no one ever knew what they were
about
[Music]
brilliance is one part talent two parts
wisdom and three parts passion
[Music]
there ain't nothing from the outside can
lick any of us
[Music]
the land is the only thing in the world
worth working for worth fighting for
worth dying for because it's the only
thing that lasts
[Music]
the people who have brains and courage
come through in the ones who haven't are
winnowed out
[Music]
when something bad happens and you can
do nothing about it what's the point of
crying
[Music]
what most people don't seem to realize
is that there is just as much money to
be made out of the wreckage of a
civilization as from the upbuilding of
one
in a weak moment i have written a book
[Music]
i love babies and kids as long as they
have not grown up and began to think as
adults lie and cheat
if if if there were so many ifs in life
never any sense of security always the
dread of losing everything
[Music]
fighting is like champagne it goes to
the heads of cowards as quickly as of
heroes
any fool can be brave on a battlefield
when it's be brave or else be killed
[Music]
to survive a family must present an
unbroken front to the world
[Music]
life's under no obligation to give us
what we expect
[Music]
burdens are for shoulders strong enough
to carry them
[Music]
with enough courage you can do without a
reputation
[Music]
after all tomorrow is another day
[Music]
i can't think about that right now if i
do i'll go crazy i'll think about that
tomorrow
[Music]
hardships make or break people
it was better to know the worst than to
wonder
[Music]
death taxes and childbirth there's never
any convenient time for any of them
[Music]
[Music]
never pass up new experiences they
enrich the mind
and apologies once postponed become
harder and harder to make and finally
impossible
[Music]
that is the one unforgivable sin in any
society be different and be damned
[Music]
i wish i could care what you do or where
you go but i can't
my dear i don't give a damn
[Music]
i only know that i love you that's your
misfortune
[Music]
now you are beginning to think for
yourself instead of letting others think
for you
that's the beginning of wisdom
[Music]
you should be kissed and by someone who
knows how
[Music]
the liar was the hottest to defend his
veracity the coward his courage the ill
bred his gentlemanliness and the cat his
honor
[Music]
her lips on his could tell him better
than all her stumbling words
[Music]
how closely women clutch the very chains
that bind them
[Music]
scarlet always save something to fear
even as you save something to love
my pet the world can forgive practically
anything except people who mind their
own business
[Music]
she saw in his eyes defeat of her wild
dreams her mad desires
[Music]
she hasn't your strength she's never had
any strength she's never had anything
but heart
[Music]
there will always be wars because men
love wars
women don't but men do
[Music]
you're like the thief who isn't the
least bit sorry he stole but is terribly
terribly sorry he's going to jail
[Music]
some mistakes are too much fun to make
only once
[Music]
the usual masculine disillusionment is
discovering that a woman has a brain
[Music]
anyone as selfish and determined as you
or is never helpless
[Music]
they knew that love snatched in the face
of danger and death was doubly sweet for
the strange excitement that went with it
[Music]
land is the only thing in the world that
amounts to anything
[Music]
the way to get a man interested and to
hold his interest was to talk about
himself and then gradually lead the
conversation around yourself and keep it
there
[Music]
[Music]
you